okay
first of all how was that performance
how was that moment that was a great
moment and you know it's been so amazing
for a song that is 100 123
old how many people just discovered it
today how many people were tweeting
about I heard it in a completely
different way
hello
[Music]
it was a different Arrangement how did
you come up with that what did you do
what I had it in my head and I worked
with my musical director at
and the two of us came together and we
got it exactly where we knew it should
be we wanted people to feel invigorated
a new inspiration for the song to know
that we have so many things we have
still yet to overcome but we can do it
it can be done
tell me about your outfit because I
heard the drama what I mean or the
changes let's talk about the changes let
me talk to your stylist your daughter my
stylist
and I found out that my mom was going to
be singing the black national anthem I
knew that it was imperative for us to
have a black designer so I reached out
to Charles Harbison we went through free
sketches my mom said I have to have a
jumpsuit I have to be comfortable I have
to be Fearless but I also have to be me
and he was able to just accommodate and
he was able to just understand what her
vision was my vision was and it came
together so beautifully down to the
detail of the choir wearing the
pan-african colors in the background
that black that red that green That was
supposed to make a statement and also in
that white that Angelic white yes
so hold on I heard you didn't get it
until Thursday is that right yesterday
we got the dress we got the jumpsuit
yesterday
wonderful woman here in Arizona named
Mary Mary came in she did the final
fitting she did the the new alterations
that we needed to have done and she came
back to the hotel at eight o'clock this
morning we got in the car at 10 and came
here were you nervous at all at eight
o'clock this morning where was your head
honestly ever shaking I was shaking I
was hoping that it was going to fit
perfectly number one and then number two
I couldn't believe that this morning was
our second fitting of the outfit but we
made it work I think it's divine and
aligned timing yes yes what did you
think about that performance at halftime
whoa
Diana started to
do what is going on because when I saw
those huge Plexiglas like massive
surfboards come in I was like what am I
seeing and listen I knew what it was
like going up three flights of stairs
without Hazard pay during Dream Girls
when I saw her going up a few hundred
feet above with nothing I was like oh my
God
was unbelievable and I was freaked out
because I said wait a minute she's in
red I was in red her background's in
white my back runs in white how did this
happen that's crazy
because when my mom's manager reached
out to me and said hey Coco what should
the buyer be wearing I was like this
should be an all-white and then maybe
some stoles for every other person we
had no idea that Brianna would be
wearing red and her background dancers
would be wearing white like this was
unintentionally intentionally planned
yeah wow what was it also like to have
your co-stars in the building and could
you see them I could not see them but I
oh my gosh right before I went on I got
a text from Quinter that said Cheryl I'm
in the building I'm here for you Lisa
Ann Walter was like I made it I'm here
we're going to be cheering you on and
then my whole cast started sending me
tweets it was just just amazing I was
watching you across the field while
they're giving out the Walter Payton Man
of the Year award and you were just kind
of standing there and centering yourself
what was going through your mind at that
moment knowing that you were basically
kicking off the festivities for the
biggest moment of the year I thought
what a wonderful honor it is for me to
be here singing this song inside the
arena with the NFL making a huge gesture
for diversity inclusion and the end of
so many of these isms that people want
to keep alive to divide us they wanted
to create a moment that brought us all
together and I believe that's exactly
what they did and I was so thankful for
them to think of me and include me for
that honor
um you've kicked off your designer life
now I mean honestly honestly you kicked
what's next I mean you've done a Super
Bowl now I know it's crazy because this
is my first like live styling
performance but no we still got award
season going on we got NAACP SAG Awards
so honestly this same energy does not
stop just be excited to see more black
designers because we want to showcase in
our partnership as mother and daughter
that black fashion black art that's
that's luxury black fashion is beautiful
black fashion is is everything we all
need you just need to see them more all
they need is a chance all they need is
somebody to bring them to the red carpet
and one of these days one of them is
going to have a table at the Met and
invite me yes last thing
what does it feel like to see your child
collect to be able to work with your
child in A Moment Like This how amazing
I know like you know to be with your
kids you look over them you're like let
me tell you something
working with my daughter as my stylist
my son as my social media content
creator I believe in nipple babies but
mommy is not giving away anything you
better earn it you better show up on
time and no I don't pay until I receive
the work and they're doing the work
done a great job mommy baby I'm a proud
mother
yes thank you
[Music]